hi there Steve Kaplan I decided to move
outside for this video can't see very
well here
squinting with the Sun in my eyes
hopefully this works out I'll have a
look later on Slavic languages my
experience on learning for to varying
degrees of fluency for different Slavic
languages and I'm going to talk a little
bit longer than my recent 3-4 minute
videos so those who aren't interested or
don't like the longer videos can turn
off the video right now um you know one
of the one thing I should say to it to
me these videos it's a form of sitting
around a coffee table and talking so I
often don't know what I'm going to say
when I start out I really wish that some
of the people who are part of my YouTube
community live nearby so that we get
together you know regularly and chat
about different things but encore of
course we can the one of the great
things about learning languages is that
it's a way of discovering the world and
of course we create our own language
worlds and we do that by finding things
of interest at least I do and whether it
be in libraries on the internet wherever
it might be and through that we create
our own language world and we discover
things about the world and I you know I
when I wrote my book on language
learning I had this reference that drums
on Taoists philosophy and I think was
louder that says that we can discover
the whole world by looking outside our
window or something I mean we have this
tremendous ability to to learn about so
many things today without going very far
so the Slavic languages I mean if we if
we look at a map of the world we see
this area north of the Black Sea this
grand vast area of steppe land were
apparently the the proto Slavic people
originated from and today we have a
great variety of Slavic languages and
they differ from each other because of
the different sort of historical
influences that affected the development
of these
languages another thing that I firmly
believe is that that culture or language
is not in any way associated with our
genes or DNA so that language doesn't
equal some kind of ethnic division
necessarily often it matches but it
doesn't have to match so we have what
they normally talk about as the Eastern
Slavic languages which is you know
Russian Belarusian and Ukranian the
Western Slavic languages which is polish
Czech Slovakian and then the southern
Slavic languages which is the languages
of the former Yugoslavia Serb Serb or
Croat Slovenian and so forth
Bulgarian my experience has been that I
studied Russian first and and I would
recommend that because Slavic language
speakers that's a large group of people
and geographically it covers obviously
most of Russia and it's not just the
sort of ethnic Russians who are Russian
speakers there's a Russian is sort of a
lingua franca in Central Asia and other
countries of the former Czarist Empire
Soviet Union so it covers all of that
and right into Eastern Europe and so I
started learning Russian because that
was the biggest one and that's where I
had exposure to Russian literature as a
teenager and wanted to read those books
in the original language and then with
the development of the whole Ukrainian
crisis I started watching Ukrainian
television couldn't understand what the
Ukrainians were saying but only what the
Russians were saying so and yet it
sounded so similar I felt as if I should
understand it and there were words there
that were similar but I just didn't
quite get the gist of what they were
saying and this gets back to to this
idea that you can't just have a few
words you know some people say if you
have a thousand words you can 70% of any
context but in fact that is never true
because very often the key words are
just those words that you don't
understand so I started learning
Ukrainian ah I should step back I did
check before Ukrainian and the reason
for that why
that my father and my parents were born
in what became Czechoslovakia they were
born in the austro-hungarian Empire so I
always wanted to learn that language
never understood any of it and I figured
now with Russian it would be easier well
it's easier okay and I'm rambling here a
bit but the grammar of those Slavic
languages that I have studied is
remarkably similar minor differences
between Polish and Russian and Ukrainian
and so forth but but remarkably similar
at least as similar as the grammar
structure you know the differences
between French Spanish Italian so it's
grammatically very similar however quite
different when it comes to vocabulary
more different than Spanish is from
Italian or from French and in a way in
terms of vocabulary the sort of outlier
that the one with the largest lexical
difference or distance as they say seems
to be Russian in other words I found
that Czech polish and Ukrainian in terms
of their vocabulary who were closer
together then was Russian although
grammatically ukrainian was closer to
russian perhaps and certainly in the
writing system that they use which is
closer it's in fact a form of Cyrillic
the reasons for this of course are all
historical there was nothing that said a
thousand years ago when the proto Slavs
were breaking up wherever they were
fifteen hundred no sorry that would have
been two thousand five whenever it was I
kept her don't remember what I read that
there would be these divisions that we
have today but there were influences
like the Orthodox Church and Church
Slavonic there was the impact of the of
the you know Mongol invasions which
meant that the original Eastern Slavic
nation built around Kiev split up and so
we have Muscovy up north and then the
southern sort of part of the kiev and
ruse became
increasingly was under the influence of
Poland Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
and so they developed more as part of
that political entity and in fact were a
significant you know the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth had a lot
more Ukrainians in it and Belarusians
than Lithuanians the military needs were
insignificant and the Lithuanian
leadership gradually became more you
know can spoke more and more polish as
Polish became the dominant language and
the poles as is often the case with
societies where you have more than one
language group they became quite
intolerant in their approach to the
orthodox ukrainians and that's why at
some point a portion of the Ukrainian
Cossacks under leadership of melnitz key
I think broke away and went off to seek
help from the Russians so with that and
over time as part of Ukraine came under
Russian control and of course they are
the Russians were less tolerant of the
Ukrainian so they tried to suppress the
Ukrainian language so you had all of
that kind of evolution and similarly
between the Czechs and and and the poles
I mean there were a lot of kings that
were common to Poland and and Czech
lands Moravia factor Reza going back a
thousand years there was even a greater
Moravia
and then in those lands you had the
Germans coming in and so lots of
different different influences including
the influence of the Catholic Church as
polish and the poles and the Czechs
became part of the Catholic world so all
of these things influenced the language
however as a learner if I were to learn
those languages I would go in the
following order I would learn Russian
first because it's the biggest biggest
in terms of numbers of speakers biggest
in terms of rightly or wrongly the
extent to which their writers are
celebrated around the world they're more
famous than polish or Czech or Ukrainian
writers this might be a prejudice on my
part but I would start with Russian and
with that you'll get the basics of the
how the grammar works although certain
minor things are different and of course
the endings are completely different but
the principles under which these
languages operate are more or less the
same and then with each language you
have to learn the vocabulary of that
language
fortunately for each one of those four
languages I have found ample resources
via the internet whether it be
audiobooks and ebooks for Russian
there's an abundance of books that you
can download and the important to link
as I said many times I found FM SP a
phenomenal resource because every day
there's tens of interviews with
transcripts put up with check I found
you know this history series tolki chess
communal Asti Yocto VG unfortunate they
no longer published the transcripts for
that but that was very helpful to me and
you can find ebooks and audio books for
check similarly with polish I was able
to find find ebooks and audio books I
haven't had the same success with
finding Ukrainian ebooks and audiobooks
because wherever you search it's all
basically this is free that is free and
I'm not that interested in free I'm
happy to pay for a decent eBook with
audio book so with Ukrainian I rely
largely on fromansky
red radio which is a very interesting
source of podcast daily on events in
Ukraine both in Russian and Ukrainian
and radio Svoboda we're often
we'll have texts with audio so there are
resources on the internet for those
languages and as you discover them you
discover this Slavic world and and there
are certain characteristics in common
and I was asked whether I found that
there was there were these similarities
between Slavic peoples and I must say
that I find that there are some but more
than that it depends on on individual
people so there are the sort of
intellectuals who are more call it
worldly there are those that are more
stridently
you know we are the best there's a whole
range and I think that's probably true
for most cultures so I am very happy
that I went after four-line which is
within the Slavic collection of
languages and I may go after the maybe
serbo-croatian particularly if I decide
to go there on holidays similarly I have
my group book of Romance languages and
it's fun to explore the differences
between Spanish Portuguese Italian
French and so forth and and of course
Romanian is a bit of an outlier Germanic
languages between my Swedish my English
and my German a little bit that I've
looked at Dutch I don't think it would
be difficult to learn so I all I can say
is it's fun to explore these different
language families and over the course of
history different people who spoke one
language maybe were converted into
speakers of another language so there's
really no connection between genetics or
genetic code or anything and language
it's more a matter of circumstance in
history and exploring these languages is
a great way to explore what we are as as
human beings oh and I should say also on
my Asian language side obviously Chinese
was a very or Mandarin was a good base
for Japanese and Korean even though
those languages although they borrowed a
lot of vocabulary from Chinese are part
of a different different language family
so there you have it in the sunshine
squinting I hope this was of interest
and for those who like the longer ramble
you got it
we'll talk again bye for now